el anuncio de este misil y personico hay
que entenderlo en el contexto en el cual
se encuentra Irán en este momento esa
fue una anuncio hecho por el comandante
de las fuerzas aeroespaciales de los
guardias revolucionarios
que ha liderado ese programa de misiles
que es la punta de lanza del programa de
defensas de Irán junto con los drones
después de semanas de haberlo negado
Irán reconoció que había vendido drones
a Rusia asegurando que había sido en
poca cantidad y antes de la guerra con
Ucrania sin embargo partes que se han
encontrado en esos misiles que han sido
capturados en Ucrania muestran que han
sido construidos después de la invasión
y esto también llega un día después de
que visitaba Teherán el secretario del
Consejo supremo de seguridad nacional
rusa y bastante cercano al presidente
Vladimir Putin Nicolás patrochef que
vino a reunirse con su homólogo y
también con el presidente iraní Ibrahim
Racing en teoría encabezaba una
delegación económica pero se ha hablado
bastante de que Rusia sigue interesado
en más drones iraníes pero también en
misiles especialmente misiles tierra a
tierra y hay alguna prensa occidental
que según sus fuentes les asegura que
estos ya se habrían comprado sin embargo
ellos siguen asegurando de que esto no
es verdad de que esto es falso Pero lo
que sí sabemos Es que este misil
hipersónico es cinco veces más rápido
que un misil normal y que tiene como
objetivo destruir esos sistemas
antimisiles del enemigo así lo ha dicho
el comandante de esta fuerza de los
guardias revolucionarios que también ha
dicho que posiblemente en 10 años no
habrá una tecnología que logre detener
este tipo de misiles y es bien
importante entender que en este momento
Irán se encuentra en una mayor
confrontación con occidente
Especialmente con Europa y con Estados
Unidos que han apoyado las protestas que
actualmente azotan al país